mais j'ai vu laurent wauquiez justement
cette semaine donc ça permette par
rapport à ce qu'il a dit de d2 un exode
pour répondre à ce que dit le président
du coup dit il
après l'élection il or il sera élu
normalement pour quatre ans donc là il
va avoir le temps le temps avec l'équipe
qui va mettre en place pour renouveler
un serveur d'idées je prends juste un
exemple notamment sur l'écologie il veut
réfléchir à une écologie
qu'ils soient de droite c'est à dire qui
ne soit pas une écologie punitive avec
on augmente les taxes ou on punit ceux
qui roulent au diesel là mais on trouve
ce que vous évoquez avec le progrès avec
d'autres éléments peut-être là une
conscription d'écologie droite sur le
social aussi il prenait l'exemple
l'autre jour il était à belfort il a
rencontré des ouvriers d'alstom et jean
la cgt dé du tout qui disent aimer
l'autre façon ils ne nous aiment pas
l'autre sa cible et emmanuel macron donc
là il ya peut-être pour la droite aussi
à rechercher toutes ses classes
populaires les ouvriers les salariés des
classes populaires qui ont déserté la
drogue depuis 2007 alors que c'était des
gens qui avaient voté pour nicolas
sarkozy il ya un discours là alors faire
visiblement on va voir on jugera sur
pièce mais laurent wauquiez a l'air
assez décidé à agir là dessus